welcome to our Wednesday show yes
during this quarantine I realize I
mentioning the day of the week a lot I'm
doing that because well if nothing else
let me be your calendar okay I can't
bring the laughs I'll tell you the day
and date maybe I'll start adding the
time and the weather yeah these are
strange times
I thought I would share with you the
look that I use when I go outside now
this is a gator that that I wear when
I'm on my bicycle over the years I've
had it for a while now I have this and
for some reason I got this hat in
Australia when we did a travel show
there not long ago I wear that too I
don't know why I wear the hat I think
it's just I like it I like the Hat and I
like this and look at that they look
like a very patriotic bank robber from
1885 anyway this is my look when I go
outside if you see this guy that's me
and you can with as long as you stay
within six feet I welcome you and I wish
you well yeah anyway uh-huh like that
and pretty good right it's sexy now I
said it's sexy
cuz no one else will Hey look I'm Bruce
Springsteen in 85 no hard feelings Bruce